6 24 on your friday morning what's cool
at school well even if the fourth or
fifth grader in your life isn't exactly
thinking about college right now the
welcome that students at wendell
williams elementary got when they showed
up on captain of the day
it is likely to stick with them
[Applause]
las vegas
just one of the 22 students from howard
university part of a 20 year old
alternative spring break program it just
made me feel warm to see that we're able
to at least give them like a jump start
in the day and say you know good morning
my name is shayla hughes i'm a freshman
criminology major they dropped it on
classes
asking a future nba star his favorite
current team principal cynthia ireland
says the college kid visit isn't just
talk what they're going to do is meet
with our fourth and fifth graders today
to set up pathway to success goals
they'll have an accountability partner
not only at school but also at home
we'll set action steps to make sure that
they are successful she put the school's
goals
in a nutshell if our boys and girls know
that we care about them and know how
much we love them and support them to be
successful they will believe in
themselves and they will soar mr wendell
p williams our namesake pours into our
students who looks like our students i
think that means the world for them to
see students from howard university and
i think it makes their dream come true
even more
just a really great story and now janaya
there she took advantage of howard's
alternative spring break program all
four years there giving younger students
a vision of what their own futures might
be congratulations now if you know
something that's cool at school let us
know cool at school under the community
tab at newsnow.com or just email us cool
at school at 8newsnow.com